just really miss him I don't think Tony
would have done what he did if he didn't
know that you were gonna be here after
he was gone you gonna be a next Iron Man
now well no I don't have time I'm too
busy doing your jobs oh I'm kidding I'm
kidding look keep up the good work
because I am going on vacation first of
all congratulations guys because Ruby is
omni's Anderson and I feel like I'm
finally recovering from infinity war
like after watching this movie nice and
for me spider-man's dusting it was
actually the hardest to watch but I'm
curious to know what were your personal
reactions to seeing spider-man get
dusted like straight up and then like
especially in an endgame when everyone
was dying out that was hilarious super
funny like the heart is like I thought
yeah I was very emotional but also
worried about my job because I could
have sworn this is something you were
supposed to do from your lawyer like oh
no Tom for you what was your reaction
when you found out spider-man was gonna
get dusted it was actually the same the
same exact reaction I was like oh that's
really cool right but I come back I'm
not actually done yeah it was it was
pretty much the same reaction okay I
still have a job what I love about this
movie tier is that you really feel like
Iron Man's ghost or like spiritually
lives on but what were your guys's
reactions when Iron Man died it was it
was pretty tough it was pretty tough
because you've all grown up with it with
Robert playing Iron Man and he's such an
iconic character everyone's looked up to
him and and I think you could argue that
his characters had the most incredible
character art from Iron Man
- endgame maybe in cinematic history you
know and we say goodbye to someone who
were your love and we will miss him and
this film is kind of like a kind of
token of our love - what Robert Downey
jr. created and Jon Favreau and with
when he made those first two films so
yeah so it's a really nice kind of love
note yeah I mean he's like good he's
still digging yeah um he had such an
incredible run you know like over a
decade and it's just a legacy by going
off that theme though Tom I'm curious to
know how long do you want to play
spider-man I honestly would play
spider-man until like I can't walk
anymore I love this character so much
and it was like my childhood dream to
play this character and you know I'm
loving it I'm really enjoying it I'm
really loving what we can do with this
movie and the people that we can kind of
touch and the amazing things we were
able to do with the platform that this
movie gives us so yes I'm just really
enjoying it I do want to ask you Tom
about your bromance with Jake Gyllenhaal
because I know you've done so many
interviews even before you were
spider-man about how much and how badly
you wanted to work with Jake so what was
that like finally I mean it was amazing
it's it's always a scary thing in the
industry when you meet someone that you
look up to because you know you want
them to live up to your expectations and
you know Jake did that and then some and
he's such a great actor he's someone
I've really admired so working with him
was kind of like a bit of a masterclass
and it just was just kind of crazy how
we became such good friends so quickly
and you know I look forward to working
with him again in the future whether
it's in a spider-man movie or whether
it's in small indie movie where we
played brothers or something but yeah
I'm just really really glad that he is
everything I would have hoped he would
be and then some are the rumors true
that it was hard to get through scenes
because you guys were just laughing yeah
totally true I mean and sometimes just
laughing at nothing like really stress a
scene in the film where we shake hands
for the first time and there was nothing
funny about the scene at all but we just
couldn't that's always
thing though it's like when you're not
supposed to laugh that's when you can't
somewhat exactly like okay now we need
you to laugh at the scene you tired or
something yeah I want to go back on my
trip with the girl who I really like and
tell her how I feel
MJ I am spider-man no of course not I
mean it's kind of obvious you're right
you may not be ready but this is my
responsibility
saving the world requires sacrifice
sometimes people die it was so
exhilarating and exciting to see you in
a spider-man movie I was so excited and
there's something somewhat seamless
about you coming into this universe and
playing a character named Mysterio given
some of your past roles so I want to
know you know did any of your smaller
indie roles informer influence your role
in this movie every role you play in
forms like the experience of a role and
I play it and all that stuff but yeah
there were sub the the themes of this
movie are some of them are somewhat
similar to other movies I've done so I
was familiar kind of with that play
particularly like the idea of you know a
rift in time and you know coming to
another space and a different time and
Continuum's and time Continuum's and
things like that so I was somewhat
familiar with what that wasn't the the
behavior that happens in that I've done
a number of movies about that idea so
yeah and then I think what Peter goes
through in this movie is similar to to
some things that characters I've been
through in movies have gone through so I
could empathize with what he was going
through
I've also obviously grown up and I'm
older than him and so because of the
character Mysterio I can impart wisdom
that I had learned in a way through
playing parts that went through things
like he went goes through in this movie
does that make sense
totally and yeah I'm sure it helps that
you've had
you know training or acting under a
bubble or fish yes yes absolutely I've
had a lot of acting in small I've done a
lot of acting small spaces partially
suffocated so yes yes I want to dive
deeper into mysterio just because he's
so iconic you know it was an issue 13 of
spider-man throughout the years we've
seen four different versions of him and
he's typically portrayed as a villain so
as much as you can tell me how different
is your Mysterio from comic book
Mysterio I mean that's what I loved
about what Marvel did when they came to
me with the idea of this character which
was that he he's very different from the
comics and because yes he appears early
on in the spider-man comics he's an
important part and he's very an
important part in the comics to Peter
Parker to spider-man but he's also not
as iconic as some other characters in
the comics and so it allows you some
leeway and I liked that because we could
change some behavior and we did and so
that gave me an opportunity to add some
things I think that would probably
wouldn't have been there you know if you
had to like stay strict to the scripture
of roles like spider-man or you know
things like that so and I love just how
they connect your character into the MCU
like I can't wait for people to find out
how that goes down it's awesome I was
just talking to Tom and he was telling
me that sometimes you guys would just be
shooting a scene and laughing about
nothing yeah I think that wasn't even
funny tell me about this bromance you
have my tongue it's a romance I'm sick
I'm really sick of people calling it a
bromance it's a romance as a legitimate
romance I find that to be very
uncomfortable when you see you know two
people the same sex you know really
falling in love he's a wonderful person
he's a devoted to his work which I love
he's obsessed with learning about the
craft which I love too and he could be
someone in his position who has a big
ego and kind of walks in with a
knowledge even when you can even at that
age though you know
you have all your insecurities as we all
do and he just not like that he's very
honest he admits to those things he
wants to listen it's just I I really
love the way he works and so when we
first started working together he's also
very gracious and very like he's really
he really liked night knows how to make
me feel special and tells me he thinks
I'm a great actor so that obviously goes
a long way but uh yeah he's just a good
dude and we actually enjoy each other
which a lot of people talking in press
junkets about other actors say but this
is true it's true if you were to play
Mysterio again would you rather play him
with spider-man Wolverine or Deadpool
well you can cross Deadpool out right
off the bat and I have so much deep
respect for Wolverine so I you know and
I same for spider-man so I can't really
you know I can't really I can't really
say oh I feel like I'm putting my
friends in danger
the world needs next Ironman you going
to step up or not
um it's so good to see your
congratulations on your 11th film in the
MCU and playing Nick Fury and it's been
so awesome just watching Nick Fury's
kind of evolution mm-hmm and in this
movie I wanted to talk to you about kind
of this new journey and new identity
that Nick Fury is on right now like
there's no more shield who is he working
for what's going on he's still working
for shield and there's still a still an
Avengers initiative it's just trying to
figure out you know what's happened in
in the blip time and what his new normal
has to be he knows what his Directorate
from Tony Stark was about Peter and he's
kind of like that that uncle or
grandfather was trying to say when
you're gonna grow up take responsibility
they tell me you're the guy but you're
not showing that you're the guy you know
he's saying you know just let me to be a
teenager for a while now you don't have
time to do that the world is not gonna
wait on you to grow up so you got to
grow up quick so I'm kind of that
pestering relative yes and I love Nick
Fury because he also just kind of keeps
the Avengers together he you know tries
to he tries to he's a glue that keeps
them all together so I want to know if
Nick Fury was never snapped what would
he have done - in the end game events
well what he did he he he knew what he
had to do and he had just enough time to
get it done and he would have been
around to see what you know Carroll was
going to do and probably would have you
know gotten in her way or tried to tell
her another way to do what she was doing
obviously you know you've been in 11
films is there a memorable Nick Fury
moment that stands out to you well the
beginning you know the first one when I
step out of the dark and Tony's house
you know the you are Iron Man you know I
am Iron Man
just kind of cool made everyone kind of
sit up and watching what happened with
Carol and when realized there were other
people in the universe that you know
needed to be dealt with and the threat
was just as as viable from out there as
it was from down here and being able to
learn that and watch him you know grow
in terms of being a naive you know
government agent into the careful and
crazy and kind of paranoid in a theory
that he is yeah I love the Nick Fury and
Captain Marvel because I feel like him
and Carol have this kind of
father/daughter relationship you know
but you see this softer side of Nick
where he's like hey mr. postman that's
my favorite Nick Fury these album
various things the oldies I would love
to hear it I'm curious so for you how
long do you want to play Nick Fury for
it because after watching this movie I'm
excited you know that he's still a
presence I want to see him go far in a
face for how long do you see yourself
playing I guess as long as I can
physically embody him and make him
believable and viable in a way you know
I don't know I don't want to overstate
my time whatever that is no I don't
think that could ever be possible no
bill no Marvel let me know I've raised
you
[Music]
you